[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello,
and welcome to
YouTube Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
I would like to introduce my
special guest, Florian Dejako,
from Elgaoto Systems.
How you doing, Florian?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: I'm great.
Hi, Jarek.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank
you for coming.
And I understand we will talk
about live streaming and
gaming today.
So let's talk a little bit
about your company.
Tell us what you guys do.
How did you get started?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Yeah.
We are Elgato Systems.
We were founded in 1999,
in Los Gatos.
That explains the. name we have
been working in software,
for many years, before we
started to found the company.
We are actually the original
developers of the Toast CD
recording software,
on the Mac.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
I remember that.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: We started
Elgato Systems to create
exciting products.
One of our first products
was EyeTV.
EyeTV turns your Mac
into a TiVo.
It is television viewing,
recording, archiving, editing,
and so forth software
that lets you
watch television, edit--
basically, everything you would
want to do with a Mac,
but many more things you can't
even do with a TiVo.
Over the years, we have
added features.
We have added different
TV standards.
We started out with just a
product for the United States,
then we added Europe.
Television-- there are
many different
standards in the world.
And we like to think we
support them all.
We have expanded to different
platforms.
We are now running on
iOS, iPad, iPhone.
We are also on Windows,
with a slightly
different software offering.
And Android as well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So when did you start working
with the gaming vertical, and
start offering the
gaming solutions?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Yeah,
gaming is a very
interesting field for us.
The interesting thing about it
is we did not find gaming,
gaming found us.
We were surprised about
the level of--
a lot of people were using our
software edition for EyeTV to
use it with hardware that was
made by another company.
And a lot of software piracy
happened in that course, where
people were basically taking
our software, and using it
with somebody else's hardware
to make recordings.
And we were wondering,
what are these
people actually doing.
We asked our users-- the
ones who paid for it--
and found out a lot of these
people don't record set-top
boxes for satellite TV and
cable television, like we
intended, with the software.
It turns out, a lot of them were
recording video games.
They were connecting
the hardware to
Playstations and Xboxes.
And the live recording feature
that was in EyeTV-- in the
EyeTV software--
which is always recording, and
that lets you jump back in
time, and continue watching
later, and so forth was
extremely useful for
these gamers.
They really enjoyed that they
could be playing for many
hours, and they were just
finally getting that one
achievement in the game, that
they were always hoping for.
And with other solutions, they
would find out that, at that
point, they forgot to hit
the record button,
and they missed it.
With EyeTV, they could just
go back in time, start the
recording then, and
then, share their
results with their friends.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Great, great.
So without further ado, can you
show us how that's done,
with Elgato Game Capture HD?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Yeah,
Game Capture--
the device itself is a video
capture device, like we've
been offering to users
for some years now.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So it's a
little box that you attach to
your game console.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: That
you attach.
It basically plugs in between
your console and your TV set.
Because we want to be able to
continue playing, obviously,
on the big screen TV.
And it captures HDMI,
or component video.
And it outputs HDMI
in full HD.
And it basically lets you
capture the video signal, as
it passes onto your TV.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So this is what we have set
up in the studio, right?
We have the Elgato box.
We have a game here, running
on our iPad, with HDMI out
coming into the box.
And then, the Elgato device is
actually connected to your mic
over USB, right?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: That is the
set up we have here.
That's correct.
On the Mac, or Windows, you run
the game capture software,
which is running here.
And that's already running.
It's already recording
my game.
And as you can see, there's a
lot of the functions going on.
But why don't I start with a
demo of the game on the iPad.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes,
show us your skills.
Can you up the volume a
little bit, so we can
hear the engine roar?
All right.
And this is "Trial Extreme
3," right?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: "Trial
Xtreme 3."
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: By Deemedya.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: And I'm new
to this, so bear with me.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: There's only
a million people watching you
right now, so no pressure.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: No pressure.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
So I'm seeing a preview of
what you're seeing on the
iPad, in the Game Capture
HD player--
I guess that's what
you guys call it.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's
a nice trick.
You can do it.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Ahh, made it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Star.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: And
there, I crashed.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Pretty good.
Oh, no.
OK.
What happens next?
So now that you failed--
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Now
that I failed
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --you gonna
show it to the world?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: --I can show
that I've been showing my
failure, live on YouTube,
already.
So what you see, here, is
my YouTube channel.
I was streaming live, from
Google Developers Live.
There's a little
bit of a delay.
So what you see is basically
that failed
run that I just made.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Got it.
So this is basically the stream
that is generated by
your desktop software, right?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: That is right.
I'm streaming, live to YouTube,
using the new YouTube
API version three.
And we've been very excited to
work with YouTube, during the
beta phase of this feature,
and to bring
streaming to the masses.
And here we go.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So just going
back to the player, can
you go back a little bit, and
tell us a little bit more
about-- you have a lot of knobs,
and a lot of functions.
What do they actually do?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Yeah.
Game Capture software--
the user interface is primarily
split up into
sections, one for capturing,
and one for editing.
And it also works,
on Macintosh and
Windows, the same way.
We have the capture side,
that I'm showing here.
At the top, I see information
about my current device.
I see my game audio, which was
coming in from the iPad.
I can also add a live
commentary.
This is useful if I have a
microphone in my room, and I
want to talk to my friends.
I want my friends to hear what
I'm saying, but my Xbox, or
PlayStation, is not actually
outputting that sound.
So we are capturing it with
a separate microphone.
And we just mix it
into the stream.
As you can see, we are currently
live streaming.
So the live streaming
section shows me
I'm on air with YouTube.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So this is the
part where you integrated
the live streaming API, right?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Correct.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So if I just
hit the button, there, you
create the broadcast, and the
stream automatically,
programmatically.
So the user never has to go to
youtube.com, and upload that.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Absolutely.
That is correct.
If you don't have a live
event scheduled
already, you get to stream--
just, we create an
event for you.
And we stream to that.
But we also support what a lot
of the more professional
gamers have been asking
us to do.
We also support selecting a
stream, or an event, that you
already created on YouTube.
So you can go to YouTube.
You can customize your event.
You can set up all the titles.
You can give a thumbnail,
and so forth.
And then, you just select it in
the Game Capture software
to stream to it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So
the use case here--
I'm a pro gamer.
I'm going to just
play my friends.
And I can actually create the
event ahead of time, promote
it, and then connect the Game
Capture HD to that event, and
start streaming, whenever the
tournament starts, for example.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: That's right.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: And at the same
time, we want to make it
easy for everybody to
use this feature.
So if you didn't do the homework
of advertising your
stream, and you just say, I'm
ready to go, just stream
already, you can do
that as well.
I can tag my video.
I can catalog by which game it
was, that I was playing.
I can give my recordings, or
my videos, a description.
And I can obviously use tags
that tie into the YouTube
tagging system.
That is the capture side.
I can now switch to the edit
side, and you see my library
of previously recorded videos.
And also, a little editor, which
you can use to mark your
highlight sections, and trim out
the bits did that you're
not so proud of.
And when you're done editing,
you can export, and share,
your video achievements with
your friends on YouTube,
Facebook, Twitter.
You can also do what a lot of
people do, is they actually
export to Final Cut Pro,
or iMovie, or Sony
Vegas, on the PC.
And they add their own
introductions, and subtitles,
and so forth.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
So you can do both.
You can live stream.
And then, you can produce a
highlights reel, by editing,
post processing, in your editor,
or in a pro editor, by
exporting that gameplay
into it.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's
really cool.
And then, you mentioned that
you don't actually have to
hunt for that perfect moment,
because your software is
running continuously.
So there is some kind of a
background recording function,
that is going on all the time.
And you go back, at any time,
and just pick a clip.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: That is right.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is that the
blue bar, at the bottom?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: The blue
bar at the bottom--
you can go back, and
you're recording.
And if you want, you can--
a lot of this is just
the start screen.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: That's what
we were doing here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So
it's a buffer.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: It
is a live buffer.
We call it flashback
recording.
We capture the last hour of
everything you played.
And at any time, you can go back
in that time and say, I
want to start my
recording here.
If you know you're going to be
good, you can just start
recording, and play.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yep.
Like you.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: I try.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So let's switch gears, and talk
a little bit more about
the technology behind
all this.
I mean, there's a lot
of pieces here.
So tell us a little more about
how is the front end
implemented, why do you need a
box, what are the protocols,
what are the APIs that
you guys have used.
For our technical audience,
I'm sure this is all very
interesting.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Yeah.
We obviously need hardware,
because otherwise, you can't
just connect a computer in
between your PlayStation and
your TV set.
That's why we have this.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
So why can't I?
Aren't there just
digital signals
coming out of the HDMI?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: The current
generations of consoles are
not really made for sharing the
content, by themselves.
So the only way to capture that
video is to connect to
HDMI, or component.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: And we encode
the signal, the
video signal, to H.264.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And this
is done by the box?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: That
is done by the box.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And it's some
kind of a chip, silicon,
you guys built?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Correct.
It is something we license,
from a company.
And the encoded signal gets
sent to the computer.
The computer records it.
We play it, using our
own H.264 decoder.
And we have all these features,
editing, live time
buffer, and so forth.
And we decode it.
We record it.
We take care of only keeping
the last hour of your
recording, and so forth.
We are very careful to make the
user experience the same,
on Mac and Windows.
We have listened to what
the games have been
asking us to do.
For instance, the live
commentary feature was
something that was created in
response to user feedback, as
well as the live streaming
feature.
People have been asking
us to stream.
And they're very happy
that YouTube,
finally, is opening up.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Right.
For those of you that are
watching, Elgato was one of
the launch partners for
the new YouTube
live streaming API.
And we have recently announced,
at Google I/O, that
we are opening up access to the
live streaming platform.
So if you are a good gamer,
and you have 1,000 or more
subscribers, you can
apply for access.
And then you can use YouTube
live streaming to show off
your skills.
And the device that you could
use to actually take care of
the encoding, and streaming,
is something
like the Capture HD.
So why was it important for
you to have the same user
experience, on Windows
and the Mac?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: We have been
very successful with that
approach, with other video
capture products.
And we find Windows users
appreciate good user
interface, just the same
as Mac users would.
And also, in designing the user
interface, it was more
consistent to make
things similar.
It goes so far that something
like our pop over window, for
instance, with detail
settings, we just
reimplemented that on Windows.
Because that is not
a thing that
normally lives on Windows.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: But we find
people click on a button once,
they see the little window pop
up, and they understand,
immediately, what's going on.
So a lot of those elements
that are very
familiar to Mac users--
they work just the
same on Windows.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then, as
far as the YouTube API--
you're using the YouTube live
streaming API, that we
launched, recently.
Are you guys doing straight
REST calls?
Are you using the
client library?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: On Mac and
Windows, those are not
implemented quite
the same way.
On the Windows implementation,
we are actually
using the C# library.
Thanks for making that.
It works quite well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great, I'll
pass that on to the team.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: And on the
Mac, we found that it was
easier to just create
requests by hand.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I see, I see.
So we do have an Objective-C
library that works quite well
on the Mac.
Is that app implemented in
C, or is it Objective-C?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: The user
interface implementation is
dictated by the operating
system.
We would love to use
Cocoa, anyway.
But on Windows, we are using
C#, with Spotnet.
And Objective-C, with
Cocoa, on the Mac.
We have a common
core of library
functions that is in C++.
We have a lot of expertise
with C++.
We've been using it for
20 years, so it works
quite well for us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then, one thing that we
always like to ask is, is
there anything that surprised
you while you were building
the product.
Anything about the users?
Anything about the API?
Anything you are you willing
to share with our audience?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Yeah.
For us, Game Capture was,
really, quite a shift in the
direction of what the
company is doing.
We have been making
these TV products.
And many of the TV
users were--
well, they were our age.
And a lot of the gamers--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Meaning
very young.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Very young.
So the gamers that we are now
working with-- they're really,
really young.
And working with these kids
is a very interesting, and
exciting, change.
A change in energy,
I would say.
It's quite interesting to be
working with these people,
17-year-old people, who have
two million subscribers on
their YouTube channel.
And it's also a very
interesting
way to market, obviously.
Every time one of these guys
holds up our product, and says
that's what they use to record,
all their fans,
obviously, hopefully want
to use the same.
And yeah, it was surprising, and
quite pleasant to see how
the young audience is
appreciating this new system,
that we introduced.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
So it sounds like you were
really closely working with
your customer, and really
changing the product to fit
their feedback.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is that why
it looks so cool and shiny?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: We listen,
and we follow
where the user is going.
And thanks to all the
gamers who keep
providing the feedback.
Keep it coming.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then, anything
about the API?
Anything that you feel
like went well,
and things that didn't?
Any features that we should be
looking into implementing?
FLORIAN DEJAKO: It's
a tough one.
Germany, for us--
I'm German, as you
may have heard--
and our company has two
offices in Germany--
they can't actually
watch the streams.
It would be great for YouTube
and the German authorities to
get pulling in the
same direction,
and actually enabling--
opening up YouTube.
And of course, all the copyright
issues that may be
attached to that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
I'll pass that feedback
to our guys.
You can pass it to the German
guys on your end.
All right.
Well, let me see if we have any
questions in our moderator.
I see one that is relevant.
I think it's addressed to me--
whether YouTube Developer
Relations is hiring.
And yes, the answer
is we are hiring.
To learn more, go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
Well, thank you very much for
taking the time to stop by our
studio, today.
It's a really fantastic
device.
I'm really happy to see the
early adopters of our YouTube
live streaming API.
And I'm looking forward for
all the great footage that
we'll see on YouTube, thanks
to a product like yours.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank
you very much.
And for those of you watching,
see you next time, next
Wednesday at 10 am, Pacific.
Bye.
FLORIAN DEJAKO: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]